stir chili in southwest Birmingham once
a rundown suburb now thanks to its parks
schools and transport links it's an
up-and-coming area with independent
businesses popping up and rising house
prices to match a couple of weeks ago I
was just a few miles down the road in
just Fitz's constituency office and I
was really shocked by the number of
people walking through the door with
really serious housing issues and it
made me determined to at least
temporarily escape the brexit fog and
cover the story so that's why we decided
to come back to Birmingham
more than six thousand families are
waiting with the council homes in
Birmingham and 3755 children and living
in temporary accommodation keen gardener
Rosie Keo knows how difficult it can be
to find somewhere to live in this city
everything's fine
I was invited back to a teenager's
office to register my interest in the
property when I told them that I
received housing benefits they told me
that they would have to and the
registration process because my being in
receipt of Housing Benefit might affect
the landlord's insurance or in mortgage
documents so how do make you feel when
you're effectively turned away I felt
really angry and I felt so frustrated
and so angry because we had no choice
but to remain in the private rented
sector because I don't qualify for
social housing so where were we supposed
to live where here would have this for
shelter this is yet more evidence of a
crisis in the housing market in the very
worst cases that's leading to
homelessness and we deal with people who
are facing homelessness because they're
not able to find accommodation where
people accept benefit recipients
I think Greg's it has consumed so much
political attention that things that the
government might be doing debates that
Parliament might be having are not
happening and that's in the context that
homelessness is now ten year high we've
got tens of thousands of children in
temporary accommodation the housing
emergency is as bad as it's ever been
but it's not being given the political
focus that it should be a government
spokesperson says everyone should have
the same opportunity when looking for
home regardless of whether they are in
receipt of benefits we welcome property
sites and lenders that have already
committed to removing no DSS adverts and
over the coming months the government
will meet industry representatives to
discuss how to end the practice once and
for all
in recent months brexit has seemed
all-consuming but in next week's local
elections and in any general election
issues like housing which directly touch
people's lives may play more of a role
than many politicians assume so he raged
Sky News burning